nos sirven pero no tienes suficientes
temas
escuchen muchas veces esa frase mientras
hacía casting tendría unos 14 años y no
había terminado de desarrollar ni por
supuesto la palabra aceptación no la
usaba con mucha frecuencia
la escuché tanto que se me volvió una
obsesión llegar a los 18 años para poder
operarle aumentar el pecho
lo hice finalmente cuando cumplir la
mayoría de edad hice todo lo que pude
para poder lograr ese gran sueño
recuerdo que cuando me desperté de la
cirugía pensaba que me sentía completa
de hecho lo decía
siempre quise ser actriz es algo que
llevo en la sangre pero también crecí
viendo a todas estas mujeres que salen
en las novelas o en las revistas tan
perfectas que yo pensaba pues de moverme
así para lograr ser un artista salir de
cali mi ciudad en colombia me fue la
capital no fue un camino fácil pero
finalmente lo logré
pude ser actriz
ya nunca nadie más me dijo que no tenía
suficientes tetas y de hecho yo me
sentía muy bien conmigo y sentía que los
demás se sentían bien conmigo y
definitivamente en ese momento pensaba
que tener tetas me daba un valor extra
como mujer
a medida que pasó el tiempo note que
empecé a enfermarme con cierta
regularidad
gripas muy fuertes cansancio frecuente
vértigos alergias constantes y bueno yo
en ese momento se lo atribuía todo a la
edad pero tenía 25 años
después me diagnosticaron tiroiditis de
hashimoto en esta enfermedad el sistema
inmune ataca la glándula tiroidea
y luego recuerdo que todo fue a peor
pero bueno los médicos siempre se
justificaban diciendo que como sufría de
la tiroides pues esta nueva
sintomatología tenía que ver con esto
luego recuerdo que las alergias
empezaron a empeorar al punto que casi
me muero literalmente cuando se me cerró
la tráquea por comer unos mariscos
cuando yo nunca había sido alérgica a
los mariscos
empecé con dolores de espalda muy
fuertes me salían morados sin causa y lo
que los médicos decían era que seguro yo
me la pasaba por ahí tropezando me con
todo y que no me daba cuenta y yo lo
único que pensaba era estaré volviéndome
loca
la temperatura de mi cuerpo comenzó a
cambiar mi cara empezó a inflamar se
sentía taquicardias y también empezó la
dislexia me gustaba mucho armar frases
sencillas tener conversaciones básicas
se me olvidaban las palabras me costaba
concentrarme y bueno yo no le prestaba
mucha atención porque si los médicos
decían que era la tiroides pues era la
tiroides yo les creía así en ese momento
lo estuviera controlado
pasaron los años mi carrera iba muy bien
y entonces fue cuando la tecnología se
puso a mi favor y conocí a mi esposo un
español que no tiene nada que ver con el
medio en el que me he movido por muchos
años y yo que de toda la vida dije que
no me iba a casar y que no iba a tener
hijos pues le aposté a esta relación nos
casamos disfrutábamos viajamos y bueno
de pronto estaba embarazada obviamente
todos estaban felices
fue un embarazo tranquilo la verdad me
enferme un par de veces pero nada grave
arianna llegó a este mundo el 6 de marzo
del 2019
fueron 32 horas de trabajo de parto y en
ese momento entendió una frase que
siempre dice mi esposo las mujeres están
hechas de otra pasta
nunca sentí un amor parecido y
de verdad puedo decir que nuestra hija
llegó a iluminarnos la vida
al segundo día después del parto tenía
mastitis
al cuarto día tuve que terminar en
urgencias nuevamente porque mi cuerpo se
estaba limpiando de una forma bastante
agresiva y luego empezaron los dolores
de caderas dolores que continuaron
durante 20 meses
empecé a perder la memoria y las uñas
cambiaron la forma en la que crecían
entonces tuvo que ser intervenida para
poder calmar el dolor las migrañas se
volvieron constantes mis defensas se
bajaban cada dos o tres días y la
energía me bajó a tal punto que yo lo
único que quería era estar en la cama
un dolor constante entre mi vientre y mi
espalda me hacía llorar con frecuencia y
cada semana me despertaba con los ojos
inflamados y morados y el pelo también
se me empezó a caer y bueno me decían en
ese momento es normal es el posparto
yo empecé a ver que empeoraba en lugar
de mejorar y entonces visité a todos los
especialistas me hicieron todo tipo de
exámenes y luego decíamos con mi esposo
que íbamos a tener que terminar en la
nasa para que me estudiarán porque los
médicos siempre llegaban a la misma
conclusión
los exámenes están bien allí tú estás
bien y no
yo no estaba bien
un día decidido compartir todo esto que
me estaba pasando en las redes sociales
entonces fue cuando empezaron a llegar
montones de mensajes de diferentes
mujeres pidiéndome que por favor
investigara algo que se llama press
implante quilmes o la enfermedad del
implante mamario hoy asociada al
síndrome de asia yo vi el primer
testimonio en vídeo y bingo llore
y me sentí profundamente agradecida
empecé a investigar el tema me metí a
los grupos de facebook y también comencé
a documentar todo con mi celular
el síndrome de asia es un síndrome
autoinmune inducido por ayub antes la
enfermedad del implante mamario es una
enfermedad que presentamos miles de
mujeres que nos hemos sometido a un
aumento de pecho
esta sintomatología tan dispersa está
toda asociada al sistema inmune
yo estaba segura que esto era lo que
tenía
es una enfermedad huérfana es una
enfermedad muy joven y que pocos conocen
de hecho muchas mujeres han sido
enviadas al psiquiatra y otras han
intentado suicidarse por esta causa
la tasa de recuperación después de
quitarse los implantes es del 86 por
ciento según yo judas aunque el doctor
que descubrió el síndrome de asia pero
hay mujeres que quedan con su sistema
inmune tan comprometido que les
diagnostican enfermedades autoinmunes
por el resto de sus vidas
siendo este mi problema seguí
investigando y después me doy cuenta que
hay un tipo de linfoma asociado al tipo
de prótesis que yo tenía
por supuesto fui a donde el médico que
me había operado y él me dijo que esto
era algo muy poco frecuente sin embargo
dos meses después mis pechos empezaron a
llenar de líquido y ese linfoma que era
tan poco frecuente se vuelve una
posibilidad real y fueron días muy
difíciles
me hicieron un examen especializado dio
como resultado negativo pero después los
pechos se me seguían llenando de líquido
entonces los médicos decían que lo que
tenía que hacer era ex plantar me lo
antes posible
ex plantarse es el proceso en el que te
sacan ese cuerpo extraño dentro de tu
cuerpo y lo deben hacer con la cápsula
que se formó al momento de poner el
implante
yo la verdad es que no tuve ninguna duda
planeamos todo debíamos viajar a
colombia y fue entonces cuando apareció
el hobby de cerraron los aeropuertos
nueve meses
nueve meses tuve que esperar para poder
operarme
nueve meses en los que los síntomas
empeoran
ya ninguna medicina me servía para
calmar el dolor
tuve un síncope vasovagal me hicieron
una astroscopia
la fatiga crónica aumentó
considerablemente y empecé a sufrir de
algo llamado apuesto condritis después
me dio una enfermedad una especie de
gripa muy fuerte que me duró mes y medio
no podía respirar
tenía fiebre mis pulmones estaban
congestionados y perdí el gusto y el
olfato sin embargo me hicieron todas las
pruebas de covite y todas daban negativo
fue irónico porque en ese momento la
enfermedad de la tiroides estaba en
remisión
[Música]
la inflamación de la cara y cuerpo se
volvió constantes los ojos se me reseca
van y la fotofobia aumentó a tal punto
que no podía manejar de noche
termo grafismo ganglios inflamados
adormecimiento en las articulaciones
sudor en las noches cambios en mi ciclo
menstrual insomnio niebla mental y
empecé a olvidar las cosas con con mucha
rapidez
la verdad es que yo pensaba que no iba a
llegar a la sala de cirugía si no se
abría el aeropuerto lo antes posible
pero bueno se dio el milagro y colombia
decide permitir los vuelos
internacionales entonces por fin pudimos
ponerle fecha a mi cirugía
18 de noviembre
el mes en el que llegue a este mundo
en la ciudad en la que llegué a este
mundo
volverían a ser o mi historia se
acabaría
organizamos todo y hablé con mi esposo
porque tuve que tener una de esas
conversaciones incómodas que uno nunca
quiere con las personas que amas le di
todas las indicaciones para que él
supiera que tenía que hacer en caso de
que a mí me pasara algo y por supuesto
lo más importante era que por favor
compartiera mi historia con nuestra hija
para que ella creciera aceptándose tal
cual es
no pude tener la misma conversación con
mis padres o con mi hermano era
demasiado difícil yo lo que sentía era
que por excelente que fuera el médico mi
cuerpo no lo iba a soportar porque
últimamente además reaccionaba al
contrario a casi todo
me despedí de mi hija
la obra
le dije que siempre siempre
y va a estar con ella sin importar lo
que pasa
entre a las siete y media de la noche a
cirugía y me desperté en unas horas
después mi primera pregunta al enfermero
fue estoy viva estás viva me dijo y
luego empecé a gritar como loca diciendo
que no sabía que el aire entraba hasta
el estómago lo había olvidado por
completo
me habían regresado de un lugar muy
oscuro
vuelve a ser yo
y luego bajo los efectos de la anestesia
entonces volvía y gritaba que no tener
tetas era lo máximo
pedí verlas
lashkar gah
y la verdad no sabía cómo había podido
cargar con s
y peso extra durante tanto tiempo de mi
vida
me sentía liviana como una pluma de
hecho me sentía mejor aún estando bajo
los efectos de la anestesia de lo que me
había sentido en los últimos años
tenemos que recordar algo
es que te estás siempre hemos tenido
siempre vamos a tener lo que ya no tenía
era ese par de siliconas que habían
robado mi salud y que aparentaban
certezas y buscaban desesperadamente la
aprobación de los demás
me abracé
me dormí esa noche
no sentía dolor y la verdad es que no
recordaba que se sentía sentir alegría
por qué
siempre
recordaba tener algo como denso oscuro
encima de mí y eso ya se había ido
desde entonces me despierto respiro
recuerdo que estoy viva y me siento
feliz
pudimos fundar un proyecto a partir de
toda esta historia y del documental que
que grabamos con mi celular que se llama
tetas grandes mi propósito en esta vida
me fue dado por medio de esta condición
ayudar
lo acepte y decidí vivir el resto de mi
vida dando a conocer esta enfermedad por
medio de nuestro proyecto pero lo que
más quiero es dejar un legado de nuestra
hija y a las mujeres que escuchan mi
testimonio porque ser mujer y ser tú
misma en un mundo que constantemente te
está pidiendo algo más es sin duda una
muestra muy clara de una palabra que
ahora uso con frecuencia
aceptación